thank you dr radovich
for those that are interested in
receiving cme credit from this
presentation
please go to the url link shown on this
on this slide
if you're part of the bio conference
live
next i'd like to just remind everyone
who are is attending this presentation
that the products shown by dr radovich
from life technologies are for
researchers only and not for diagnostic
procedures
i also like to recommend that if anyone
is interested in learning more about rna
sequencing
transcriptome the ion torrent proton
there's information available in the
life technologies booth
at this point as there does not appear
to be any additional questions i'd like
to thank dr radovich again and everyone
who attended the presentation thank you
thank you for joining
my name is michaelene bunting and i will
be the moderator for today's
presentation
on behalf of life technologies it's my
sincere pleasure to introduce dr milan
assistant professor of the department of
surgery
indiana university school of medicine a
member of the melvin and bren simon
cancer center and center for
computational biology and bioinformatics
dr radovich will be speaking on the
transcriptome sequencing in
translational oncology research this
presentation is available for cme credit
and i will have more information
available at the end of the presentation
we'll also be taking questions and
answers during the presentation and i'll
be facilitating that session at the end
dr ravitch
okay um mike lane thank you so much for
the fantastic introduction and i also
like to thank life technologies and the
organizers of bioconference live for
allowing me to present this webinar
today on transcriptome sequencing and
translational oncology research
as a quick overview i'm going to give a
very brief introduction to cancer
genomic sequencing and why we perform
next-gen sequencing and oncology
research and then delve into
our primary focus is work in genomic
sequencing in triple negative breast
cancer and then end off with some of our
work and applying it as
correlatives in clinical research
studies
so when i give a talk to a varied
audience i always like to start off with
this slide to kind of go over the
history of how genomic sequencing has
evolved over the decades
many on this webinar will probably
remember the days of sequencing dna
using
gel-based terminator sequencing and as
the technology evolved into the 2000s we
moved into capillary
base sequencing as many would remember
these sequencers were the workhorses of
the human genome project uh churning out
millions of bases per day at three major
genome centers
after the advent of after we got through
the 2000s and we came upon the advent of
next generation sequencing in 2005
we saw a just a plethora of instruments
come out onto the market
uh coming now to today these instruments
producing on orders of billions of bases
per day and in the near future the
advent of nanopore technology and single
molecule technology
why we're so interested in the idea of
using genomics and studying cancer is
that for many as many people know in
this room the purpose of uh or the cause
of cancer is a dna based disease we know
that cancer in its essence is due to
mutations
to the genomes of cancer cells
so this figure published in nature a
couple years back is a fantastic figure
describing this accumulation of cancer
mutations as a as
as are caused through a variety of
processes first
there are intrinsic mutation processes
so as cells move from
fertilization as infancy childhood
adulthood and clonal expansion we know
that they're intrinsic mutations that
are generated these are mutations that
are generated due to just dna the dna
replication machinery though that
machinery is quite good at what it does
it's not perfect and every once in a
while mutations are introduced
we also know that there are mutations
that are introduced due to environmental
and lifestyle exposures things such as
smoking sunlight and a variety of
carcinogens also add mutations to the
genomes
but we know that many of these mutations
are actually what we call passenger
mutations as depicted by these yellow
and blue dots mutations are introduced
in the genome but cause no change in
protein function
what unfortunately happens is the
accumulation of driver mutations these
are the ones present in stars these are
mutations that affect tumor suppressors
and oncogenes and as they accumulate
begin to transform the cell from normal
cell to early clonal expansion to benign
tumor early invasive cancer late
invasive cancer and then obviously what
we're most concerned with is chemo
resistant disease
we also know with recent data published
in major journals like new england
journal medicine here is that tumors
themselves are highly heterogeneous
in this fantastic paper published in the
new england in 2012 we a sequencing of a
large renal cell tumor where the
investigators took multiple punch
biopsies in 10 different sites with the
tumor and also within the chest wall
metastasis and the lung metastases and
then sequence each of these sites and
what came out of this work was a very
interesting observation that within
these
various sites there are mutations that
are shared among all the parts of the
tumors and the metastases but there's
also mutations that are shared only in
the primary that are not seen in
metastases and vice versa but also
mutations are specific to each
physical site within the tumor
engendering that a massive amount of
heterogeneity mutationally is present in
these tumors such that they actually
form a evolutionary tree and as these
tumors evolved and as they continue to
grow into these large masses actually a
microcosm of evolutionary
divergent evolution occurring in which
mutations are selected
are gained advantage as the tumor grows
and then begins to metastasize
we also know that these mutations uh
actually these accumulation mutations in
the key tumor stresses oncogenes then
translate into different differences at
the rna expression level here i show
principal components analysis of some
example data of 10 normal tissues and 10
tumor tissues
where we see
based on rna-seq expression the
principal components analysis for those
who are not familiar is basically a 3-d
representation of gene expression on a
global level such that
samples that are more alike on their
gene expression level are bald together
and then samples that are more different
or distal like based on their gene
expression level are separated and here
we can see a wide separation between the
tumor normal samples and it's not
uncommon to see a dysregulation an
expression of thousands of protein
coding genes and the transformation of
normal cells to tumors
with the advent of of all this of this
sequencing technology both dna and rna
the national cancer institute has
instituted the nation of the cancer
genome atlas
as mentioned this is a large national
cancer institute initiative this
characterized more than 10 000 tumors
and 24 tumor types by 2015.
and in this initiative they are applying
a variety of sequencing chemistry
modalities including dna sequencing rna
sequencing mic rna-seq snip arrays
reverse phase protein arrays methylation
assays from tumor normal pairs with the
goal of creating a comprehensively
public catalog of all significantly
recurrent genomic alterations
what is fantastic about the tcga is that
is its comprehensiveness here is
actually a truncated list of the major
tumor types being considered are being
sequenced by the tcga in addition to
this list there's a variety of rare
tumors there are
tumors that are being sequenced also as
part of a rare tumor initiative
further what is advantageous about the
tcga is that all this data is made
publicly available for investigators to
use in the community
both be available the tcga data portal
and also available through the the raw
data through the
ucscg hub
here just an amazing resource of of
next-gen uh mentioned dna rna and
metallusique and variety chemistry is to
be used for translational oncology
research
so
i kind of given you an interview a uh
intro to
genomic sequencing the cancer but why
the question is why do we do it i think
it's advantageous that we can take these
technologies and be able to interrogate
at the molecular level in
amazing different amount of facets but
why do we want to do this when we take
this to the human level
we know that human cancer is the
combination of dna mutations and rna
dysregulation and that this combination
mutations and rna dysregulation is
lethal
also sobering the treatment for cancer
in the last 30 years has remained
largely unchanged drugs that are still
mainstay first line therapy for common
common chemotherapeutics like paclitaxel
cisplatin and cyclophosphamide
were actually discovered in 1950s and
60s but still remain
mainstay chemotherapy for many patients
and while drugs that specifically target
cancer cells are under development
targeted therapies that drastically
extend survival have been few and far
between that's not to say that there
haven't been a large a good group of
blockbusters such as herceptin the
aromatase inhibitors crozotinib and so
on but those those
drugs have been very specific to very
specific populations and ones that
targeted therapies that impact larger
cancer populations have yet to be
discovered
so what are some major questions in
cancer research
one what mutated genes and or pathways
are critical for the development of
common cancers
what are the key drug targets for the
development of novel therapeutics
what molecular changes cause chemo
resistance
and are there better biomarkers for the
early detection of cancer
also are there better biomarkers for
predicting prognosis and treatment
outcome
and one of the questions we can ask is
can cancer transcriptome sequencing help
answer these questions
so what i'd like to do now is actually
show you how we in our group have
applied cancer transcriptome sequencing
to study triple negative breast cancer
for some in the audience may already
know what triple negative breast cancer
is but for those who don't i like to
introduce the disease
and how we define it
so first a patient with a diagnosis of
breast cancer there's going to be a
biopsy that primary tumor and that
primary tumor biopsy is going to be sent
for pathology to have a variety of
immunohistochemical stains
one of the first things that that tumor
is going to is going to be stained for
is for the estrogen receptor and
progesterone receptor about 75 percent
of breast cancers are going to over
express these two proteins in addition
to standard chemotherapy are going to
receive drugs that target the estrogen
receptor including tamoxifen fulvestrine
and neuromutase inhibitors
another 15 of breast cancers are going
to over express or over amplify the her2
oncogene a cell surface receptor
tyrosine kinase in addition to
chemotherapy these patients will receive
drugs that target her2 like herceptin
lapatinib and the newer molecule tdm1
another 15 to 20 or so of breast cancers
are what we call triple negative these
are patients who are negative for er pr
and her2 in addition to standard
chemotherapy there are no targeted
agents currently available
this lack of target agents has actually
translated into a poor overall survival
here a publication by dented allen ccr
in 2007 shows an overall survival
kepler-meyer curve of all other breast
cancers versus triple negative breast
cancers as as you can see patients with
triple negative breast cancers a
diagnosis entails an overall poor
prognosis
so what are some details about this
cancer as i mentioned about 10 to 15 of
all breast cancers with a
disproportionately higher mortality
it has a higher proportion
affecting premenopausal women and women
of african descent
we also know that the majority of braca
one breast cancers are triple negative
meaning if a patient is a germline
carrier of the bracha one
gene or mutation in the bracket one gene
if they develop breast cancer they tend
to develop triple negative breast cancer
in addition to being high risk for
ovarian cancer
and as i mentioned before there's a
paucity of effective targeted therapies
and the question we ask ourselves is
that scientists where can we look to
better define this disease and to find
new therapeutic targets
to do this we embarked on a
comprehensive rna sequencing study where
we took 20 normal micro dissected normal
breast tissues from healthy volunteers
from our susan g komen for the cure
tissue bank at the iu simon cancer
center
in addition we sequenced 10 triple
negative breast cancer tissue samples
from our institution
we then merged the data with 84 triple
negative breast cancers and 10 adjacent
to tumor normal tissues from the cancer
genome atlas in a combined analysis
we merge normalize and analyze the data
using a variety of software both
developed at our center for
computational biology and bioinformatics
along with third-party software from a
variety of vendors including life
technologies fire tech and ingenuity
systems
one of the most important parts of our
study was our use of normal control
here is actually a picture of an h e
stain of our normal breast tissues where
you can see the blue circular ducts
represent the milk ducts present in the
normal breast the importance of this
study was that we microdissected our
normal ducts and you extract the rna
from the normal tissue from the normal
duct tissue as our comparator to cancer
the reason being is that the origin of
breast cancer is within the ductal
epithelium as also known the majority
cell type that makes up the normal
breast consists of fibrous tissue
fat stroma and we wanted to enrich for
the rna specific to this area that's the
origin of breast cancer
what was neat was these are actual
samples donated from healthy volunteers
that are present as part of the susan g
komen tissue banks and were chosen as
part of a larger bank of 1500 breast
normal tissues
with matched serum plasma dna and a full
medical history and we were able
actually to capture all that data in our
analyses
one of our first results was a principal
components analysis of the rna-seq
expression of these various groups
here in blue are the common tissue bank
microsecond normal tissues
in green are the adjacent normal tissues
from tcga
the purple are the triple negative
breast cancers from tcga and the red
represent the triple negative breast
cancers that we sequence from indiana
university as you can see in this
principle components analysis is a vast
difference in the transcriptomic profile
between these various groups
and without having the time to go into
all the details
we have a considerable number of genes
that separate these groups including
roughly 3000 genes that separate
microsecond normal tissue from triple
negative breast cancer
here is actually the venn diagram of the
number of genes that differentiate these
groups so here in the then on the top
and the pink you have the the number of
genes that separate adjacent normal from
micro dissected about 946 genes
the number of genes that separate triple
negative from micro dissected normal 32
3261 genes and on the bottom right the
number of genes of triple negative
versus adjacent normal tissues at 3353
genes
one of the analysis that we want to take
when we developed this data was to get a
global idea of what really differentiate
these type these tissue types so we
perform the canonical pathway analysis
comparing these groups in the triple
negative versus microdissecting normal
we see pathways including role back 1
and dna damage response like i mentioned
dna damage in brac 1 is very important
in the etiology of triple negative
breast cancer and including other
cancer-specific pathways like cell cycle
and cell cycle control over chromosomal
chromosomal replication but also
something that we also expected was
immune pathways pathways like dendritic
cell maturation and il-8 signaling as
it's well-known triple negative that
immune
infiltration is a major component of
this cancer
on the right side when we compare to
adjacent normal we actually see some of
the same pathways we see when compared
to micro dissecting normal like braco
one cell cycle but we also see other
pathways more indicative of stroma
pathways like atherosclerosis hepatic
fibrosis and estrogen-mediated s-phase
entry
the stark difference in these two
controls becomes more evident when you
look at
pathways that are very specific though
to both the analyses so here these are
pathways that of the genes that do not
overlap on the venn diagram so these
include
on the left side with triple negative
micro sector normal
many immune pathways like antigen
angiogram presentation dendritic cell
maturation n fat one regulation immune
response
but when we look at the right side when
we use the adjacent normal comparator we
actually get pathways with smaller p
values and ones with pathways not as
intuitive like melatonin degradation lxr
activation and one in further analysis
we've dug deeper into these what these
were genes involved in activated stroma
some of the some of the reasoning behind
why we may see these differences include
the fact that in our microdissected
normal we had actually went through the
process of laboriously micro dissecting
these tissues where the adjacent normal
tissue represents a whole tissue
conglomerate but also the fact that
tumors are very well known to secrete a
considerable amount of factors into the
into the local micro environment such
that these factors can play a strong
role in influencing the tumor
microenvironment and the adjacent normal
micro environment such as dysregulating
genes and again when we looked deeper
into the data we saw many cancer genes
in adjacent normal actually up regulated
potentially due to this microenvironment
effect
another thing analysis that we did was
actually perform what we call an
upstream regulator analysis this is a
very cool analysis that takes the
differential gene expression and then
based on a large literature database is
able to predict whether an upstream
activator is inhibited or activated
in this analysis when we took our
differential express genes between
triple negative and microdissecting
normal we found our we present here our
top three inhibited transcription
factors and those that are activated
interestingly this data was congruent
with no dna mutational events present
triple negative breast cancer
for example the transmission factor p53
was inhibited in our analysis p53 is the
number one most mutated gene in triple
negative breast cancer with a prevalence
above 80 percent
we also found cdkn2a or p16 to be
inhibited as common in many cancers and
also rb1 to be inhibited which has been
reported to have a 72 percent loss of
heterozygosity in triple negative breast
cancer
conversely on the activation state with
rb1 being inhibited we find its
canonical target e2f1 activated
we also find the make oncogene activated
and make is known to be amplified in a
large proportion of triple negatives and
we also in congruence with the data from
the tcga find the transcription factor
fox m1 to be activated this is a
transcription factor known to be
involved in metastases and i'll actually
come back near the end of my talk to
talk a little bit more about fox m1
so this idea between
triple neg versus normal at the
molecular level is a very interesting
story but what happens when we take it
to the therapeutic level and the reason
we take it to the therapeutic levels may
be to begin to get an idea of some
responses of targeted therapies and
triple negative breast cancer i did
mention to you earlier in the talk there
are no currently fda approved targeted
therapies for triple negative breast
cancer that doesn't mean that it hasn't
been tried and there's roughly now six
to seven phase two clinical trials
testing targeted agents in triple
negative breast cancer
what i show here is actually the
conglomerate of those trials where on
the left i show the treatment that was
used in the phase two clinical trial the
target
the rationale for testing that target
based on previous tumor versus tumor
data and then also what we see in the
tumor versus normal data what i mean by
tumor versus tumor data is in many
studies finding targets and triple
negative breast cancer were based by
comparing triple negative breast cancer
to other subtypes of breast cancer or to
benign disease
possibly leading to potentially
identifying a therapeutic target but
also potentially finding passenger
targets
here i'm also going to show you what the
results are when we actually take the
triple negative breast cancer but this
time compared to a normal tissue
the first therapy is the tuxedo map and
trufitinib which inhibit the egfr based
on prior data that egfr is overexpressed
in triple negative breast cancer
interestingly when we compare to the
normal to microsecond normal breast we
don't find egfr on average to be
overexpressed we actually find no
differential expression this is an
observation that was confirmed by qpcr
and also by clia based ihc staining
and clinical trials testing egfr
inhibitors and triple triple negative
have been all been negative
the agents imatinib and the satinib
which target the c-kit receptor also
based on prior data the c-kit is
overexpressed in triple negative breast
cancer
compared to normal breasts we actually
find it not to be over actually
significantly down regulated
interestingly the normal breast ductal
epithelium expresses high amounts of
c-kip and two clinical trials testing
these inhibitors in triple negative
breast cancer have been negative
the parp inhibitors drugs like nipperib
elaborate in your cap rib and many
others are currently in clinical trial
that target the parp
harp is a dna repair enzyme and this
repair rationale is based on over
expression of parp and also also via
synthetic lethality especially in brac
one carriers in dna repair
we find part actually to be
overexpressed and triple negative
compared to normal with a four-fold
over expression with significant p-value
and actually park inhibitors are the
only
agents to show some positivity in triple
negative
the results have been slightly mixed
based on seeing more activity in bracket
one carriers versus those or not and
also some
recent work describing potential lack of
potency in some parp inhibitors but some
newer partners that are on the market
are beginning to show activity in this
disease and are
seemingly right now to be a promising
candidate for targeting triple negative
breast cancer
so the question is is
if some of those targeted therapies i
showed you before like egfr kit are not
the target agents we need to use so what
are the right targets so one of the
other analysis that we performed using
this data set was going to perform
pathway analysis look at trying to
identify novel therapeutic targets for
this disease here i show you the pi3k
pathway pi3k akt pathway in our data set
where those genes in red are those are
over expressed in the triple negative
breast cancer versus normal and here we
can see many genes involved in pi3k akt
pathways overexpress in this disease
to test the sensitivity of triple
negative to pi3k inhibitors we tested a
panel of seven triple negative breast
cancer cell lines acro against a panel a
variety of pi3k akt and dual pi3k mtor
inhibitors that are either in phase two
or phase three clinical trial in in
triple negative breast cancer in uh in
actually all cancer patients and pan
cancer patients
what we saw
very nicely is actually a strong
sensitivity of triple negative breast
cancers to these inhibitors
here is actually the cell line md nva
mb231 which was actually the most
resistant cell line to these inhibitors
and even among in the most resistant
cell line we see nice and sensitivity of
these cells to to these pi3k akt and
mtor uh
small molecules
such that when we test the uh when we
test these inhibitors across the triple
negative breast cancer cell lines we see
many of our results in the nanomolar
ic50 levels
but as we know with cancer targeting one
hitting one target rarely works even if
we see response the tumor becomes does
become resistant engendering the
possibility of the promise of doing
combination therapy so we saw that we
set out to use the same transcriptome
sequencing to see if we can discover
rational combinations
as i mentioned to you before also that
genes like egfr and kid have failed in
clinical trial and their one their
promises is because they're powerful
molecules
cell surface receptor tyrosine kinases
so we've decided to if to look at
actually the whole genome expression of
receptor tyrosine kinases in our data
set
here is a volcano plot plotting the full
change of these receptor tyrosine
kinases of triple negative versus normal
on the x-axis and the p-value of the
differential expression on the y-axis as
you can see
on the top left genes like kit that were
tested before clinical trial and egfr
here are either significantly down
regulated or not differentially
expressed what's interesting is the gene
interesting is the genes on the
top right of this v
here genes like the receptor tyrosine
kinase ptk7 and fmb2 actually prior to
this analysis we were not very familiar
with this protein ptk7
what it is is a canonical wind
co-receptor present on the surface of
cells and was first discovered to be
over thrust in colon cancer tissue and
not normal tissue and his primary role
is involved in epithelial planar
development
this
led us to delve deeper into the wind
pathway here we show a canonical pathway
analysis comparing
triple neg normal here on the wimp
pathway and we find a variety of genes
involved in the wind pathway to be
overexpressed in triple negative breast
cancer
this observation led us to test the
combination therapy of pi3k and
inhibiting pi3k and wind
we sought to find a wind pathway
inhibitor available
for
available publicly available and we
found this wind pathway in hybrid fh 535
first developed in 2008 the fred
hutchinson cancer center and the
important inhibitor of the beta catenin
and p par alpha and gamma signaling
what was interesting is when we put
these
drugs together
here again the same resistance cell and
the
mb 231 treated both with the pi3k
inhibitor bkm120 and the wind inhibitor
fh535
in purple you're seeing a long dose
increase of bk and 120
in blue you see a log dose increase of
the cells treated with fh 535 and in the
yellow you see the combination where
bkm120 is held at a very small
concentration of 10 nanomolar with
increasing doses of h535
what's very interesting is we saw
extensive synergy across all seven cell
lines when putting both these inhibitors
together
interestingly with ic50 is approaching
single digit nanomolar levels
so what we what we're seeing here is a
very strong synergy of hitting these two
powerful pathways together against this
disease
to get an idea of why this combination
is seemingly so efficacious we performed
an rna-seq experiment again going back
to transcriptome sequencing where we
took triple negative breast cancer cells
and treated them with the pi3k inhibitor
btm 120 and then performed rna
sequencing before and after treatment
what was very interesting was to see
that the important genes involved in the
wind pathway were actually becoming
overexpressed or induce their expression
induced by the presence of bkm120
meaning when the cells were treated with
pi3k when we knocked down this
overcharged pi3k the wind pathway genes
were becoming overexpressed and such
that when we were hitting the wind
pathway with the fh 535 we're knocking
down both pathways and potentially
inducing a synergistic reaction in cell
viability
very akin to the game of whack-a-mole
where one hits the mole in one with
another mole popping up and then we hit
both
here genes like porcupine which is a
wind maturation protein involved in this
palmitalation being overexpressed eight
fold and also several cell surfaces
with receptors like frizzle one frizzle
two and also ptk7
this work is now actually being further
taken with a combination of inhibitors
that target uh pi3k and also porcupine
now being tested in v-bone
patient-derived mouse xenographs
another aspect that we took advantage of
rna sequencing was to actually study the
heterogeneity of this disease as i
mentioned in introduction dna mutational
based heterogeneity is being actively
studied in
a variety of cancers and we want to see
if we can apply the same heterogeneous
heterogeneity concept to rna sequencing
and triple negative breast cancer
so what we did in this analysis was to
take all of our 94 triple negs and
compare each one individually to the
panel of 20 micro dissected normals and
what you have plotted here on the x axis
is each of those individual triple
negative breast cancer and the y axis
the number of differentially expressed
genes that are different between each of
those individual triple negatives and
what we see is a wide variety a wide
range of the number of genes that differ
to differentiate each individual tumor
such that we have roughly at the high
end roughly about 3600 genes are
differentially expressed between a
triple negative and a normal tissue that
range all the way down to as little as
1300 genes and what we see is actually a
wide swatch of heterogeneous
heterogeneity and the number of of
transcriptional dysregulated genes in
our data set
we've internally referred to this as
transcriptional chaos
what's further interesting was was when
we correlated this transcriptional chaos
i.e the number of differentially
expressed genes per triple negative to
the total number of non-silent dna
mutations from tcga so what we did was
to download the number the non-sound
gene mutations from the broad firehose
application
tcga and then perform a correlation
analysis transcriptional chaos and what
we saw was a correlation between the
burden of the number of non-silent
mutations of tcga translating into the
number of differentially expressed genes
in transcriptional chaos
what also was further interesting was
how this transcriptional chaos actually
explains overall
global transcriptional heterogeneity so
here you're seeing a unsupervised pca
plot of our 94 triple negative breast
cancers where on the left you see the
triple negative breast cancers colored
by the bottom and top quartiles of the
transcriptional chaos and on the right
separated by
known triple negative breast cancer
molecular subtypes
if you were to rotate this pca plot if
we were able to do that on
during this talk you would see that the
known molecular subtypes the vanderbilt
tmbc types do separate the triple
negative breast cancers into
into their
seven different subtypes
but we also notice is that the
transitional chaos on its own also
separates the triple negative breast
cancer into these two groups just based
on the number of differentially
expressed genes that separate uh
each individual triple negative to
normal engendering that
that in addition to non-molecular
subtypes the transitional chaos plays an
important role in understanding the
heterogeneity of this disease and we
have quite a bit of more further data
not presented here showing how the
transitional chaos plays a role in
differentiating heterogeneity of triple
negative breast cancer
as i also men as mentioned before we see
again a wide range of the number of
genes that differentiate express and
mediate this chaos of 1300 to 3500 genes
and interestingly this represents about
14 000 genes in the genome as you can
imagine about there's 20 000 roughly or
so expressed genes in the human genome
protein coding genes and the scriptures
on chaos analysis encompass roughly 14
000 of those
we also as i mentioned this chaos is
dictated by mutational heterogeneity and
probably and definitely dictated by a
variety of common mutations like pvp3
pick 3ca rb1 and mic as i mentioned
before but also many other less frequent
mutations
this led us to ask this question that in
the midst of this chaos is there any
commonalities that act as denominators
of this chaos
what's interesting is when we looked at
the analysis we found actually only 146
genes tm we refer to the core genes that
were differentially expressed in greater
than 90 of triple negative breast
cancers meaning even though the chaos
analysis accompanies as many as 14 000
genes the denominator between these
diseases is very small only about 146
genes are analysis
what's further interesting was one of
those 146 genes is fox m1 which we found
to be overexpressed 20 fold in these
triple negative breast cancers and
activate it in our analysis
what was interesting further interesting
is when we took this fox m1 and
performed a local network analysis what
we found was when we just focused on
those genes of those 146 genes in that
core analysis we found foxen one to
directly uh
regulate is a subset of those 146 genes
roughly 15 or so genes that are directly
regulated by fox m1
when we took it to the second level we
took the network analysis one hop we
found a larger number of those 746 genes
being regulated by this fox m1 network
interestingly roughly 46 of those 146
genes being regulated by this once
transcription factor so what's
interesting is that even among even
though the denominator the number of
genes that that are the same across
these 146 in terms of transcriptional
chaos 146 genes across 94 we find that a
lot of that heterogeneity is being
dictated by one major transcription
factor we've further done additional
analyses and found a couple other
regulators of those core genes
so i'd like to end off as i'm the title
of my talk is is about next generation
sequencing translational oncology
research i want to take also
talk about a little bit about how we're
applying sequencing for coordinates in
clinical research studies
one of our current studies is actually
applying next-gen sequencing to a
recently completed randomized phase 2
clinical trial of triple negative breast
cancer or erp are positive her2 negative
with known brachial two mutations
this is it what is referred to as a
postnew adjuvant trial here patients uh
receive new aging chemotherapy or
chemotherapy prior to surgery
and normally after at the time of
surgery there's two responses one is a
pathologically response meaning the
chemotherapy had ablated an entire tumor
and there's no tumor at the time of
surgery
or the other responds to significant
residual disease meaning disease is is
present at the time of surgery
we know that patients who who observe
who gain a pathological complete
response do well
after a surgery but we know patients who
have residual disease tend to do poorly
in many in many cases a large proportion
relapse with metastatic disease so this
trial is innovative in a couple of ways
current standard therapy for patients
with triple negative breast cancer who
have significant residual disease after
surgery is actually wait and see or
physician choice there is no standard
therapy for this population so this
trial is innovative in that it
actually randomizes patients to a
therapy in this case this plan for four
cycles which is a dna damage and
chemotherapy or cis platinum plus recap
rib uh
which recap is an experimental part
inhibitor for four cycles followed by
maintenance therapy of vocabulary for 24
weeks
this trial enrolled 135 patients with
enrollment completed in early june with
primary endpoints of one year and
two-year disease-free survival
from this analysis we are obtaining a
variety of biospecimens for corollary
genomic sciences this includes a pre
biopsy pre-treatment prior to neutral
chemotherapy a specimen of surgery and
also normal blood and plasma to perform
correlated genomic sciences using a
variety of sequencing modalities listed
here
we're going to be applying a whole exome
sequencing using ion proton sequencer to
discover germline somatic mutations rna
sequencing to profile this regulated
gene expression and also profiling the
plasma dna to detect circulating tumor
dna as a biomarker of relapse
our goals from the study is to determine
the mutational and expression changes in
the tumor that mediate resistance to
after new adrenal chemotherapy meaning
can we find uh signatures or mutations
that make these tumors resistance in the
first place such that these patients
develop residual disease after new
adjuvant chemotherapy to determine gene
expression signatures and mutated
pathways that predict response to the
experimental arm of cisplatin and
recapyrib
to test germline variation as biomarkers
for treatment response we know
that germline dna variations
particularly how our how enzymes
metabolize drugs
have a play a major role in our response
to both drug efficacy and also to
toxicity
lastly we'll be assessing the
circulating tumor dna as an accurate
biomarker for relapse
one of one of the challenges when we
sequence from clinical trials is that
the samples we get can be very
difficult to work with and can be
challenging as one can imagine many of
these clinical trials are multi-site
trials present across variety of states
and sometimes internationally
executed across various countries and
these samples come in all
variety of uh call it shapes and sizes
that are obtained by the lab such that
sometimes we get very uh good tumors
showing up or left with plenty of tumor
cellularity sometimes we get tumors that
are jet are like on the upper right that
are intertwined with a variety of
stromal cells or sometimes we get tumors
like on the on the bottom here and
center where comprised mostly of stroma
scar tissue and with very little tumor
making and many times almost all samples
being formally fixed perfect embedded
providing an extra challenge for the
study of these samples using next-gen
sequencing
so as we've embarked on sequencing this
clinical trial we performed quite an
extensive quality control analysis to
make sure that we can be successful in
sequencing difficult samples
here we show data where we perform
proton paraffin rna sequencing of the
same sample with a one thousand nanogram
input and also with a very small 50
nanogram input of fragmented art of ffp
rna here we plot the log2 rpkm or the
digital expression values of these
libraries against each other and we
should we demonstrate a very strong
nice correlation between these two
libraries with an r value approaching
0.92
this is very exciting for our standpoint
is that it shows that low input ffp rna
sequencing is feasible from paraffin
tissues at very low inputs
and we've actually replicated this with
other paraffin tissues and shown that
this is actually doable with samples
from a clinical trial
albeit sometimes depending on the age of
the study can affect the
the results of these sort of sequencing
studies but so far we've had very good
uh very good results testing
rna-seq on paraffin tissue from clinical
trials
and with that i'd like to end my talk
and thank just my wonderful
collaborators who made a lot of this
work possible my collaborators here at
the iu school of medicine for medical
oncology dr schneider and george sledge
who just recently moved to stanford
dr sioux clare dr lair ivan nephew lou
and badve and also members of my
laboratory uh jeff solzak ratujatali and
brad hancock along with the wonderful
folks of the susan g komen for the cure
tissue bank who made the study possible
by providing normal breast tissues from
a wonderful repository
available to the public for breast
cancer research
also for those of you who are interested
in a little bit more about what we do my
laboratory loves to maintain a facebook
page
with the research and also some of our
more fun photos and please come see us
there at facebook
and with that i'd like to send it back
to mclean i thank you for your attention
today